[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Anne Gellinek
guten Abend nun kommt der also doch fast
löst die Nachricht Erleichterung aus
dass der ukrainische Präsident wurde mir
selenski morgen in Berlin erwartet wird
die Vorgeschichte dieses Besuchs ist so
kompliziert und verkrampft wie die
deutsch-ukrainischen Beziehungen selbst
Kanzler Scholz war so ziemlich als
Letzter europäischer Regierungschef nach
Kiew gereist silensky hatte bisher einen
großen Bogen um Berlin gemacht nun aber
soll alles anders werden und wie um das
zu unterstreichen verkündete die
Bundesregierung heute schon ihr
Begrüßungsgeschenk ein
milliardenschweres Waffen
Unterstützungspaket für die Ukraine am
Vormittag landete selensky zunächst in
Rom Christiane hübscher berichtet
eine große Ehre sei es für ihn sagt
wolodemir selensky als der Papst ihn im
Vatikan begrüßt 40 Minuten werden Sie
gleich zusammen sprechen Papst
franziskus versucht seit Kriegsbeginn
neutral zu bleiben nur so könne er eines
Tages als friedensvermittler zwischen
der Ukraine und Russland in Frage kommen
das ist keine Haltung findet der
ukrainische Präsident und teilt nach
seiner Audienz schriftlich mit ich habe
Papst franziskus getroffen ich habe ihn
gebeten Russlands Verbrechen in der
Ukraine zu verurteilen denn Opfer und
Aggressor können nicht gleichgesetzt
werden
selensky trifft in Rom auch die
italienische Regierungschefin Meloni sie
sagt ihm weitere finanzielle und
militärische Hilfen zu das größte
Hilfspaket aber wird sich selenski wohl
morgen in Berlin abholen höchste
Sicherheitsstufe im Regierungsviertel
Details zum Besuch des ukrainischen
Präsidenten noch geheim nur das
Begrüßungsgeschenk steht schon fest der
deutsche Verteidigungsminister kündigte
Waffenlieferungen im nie dagewesenen
Umfang an das größte Paket was bislang
in einem Paket zustande kommt und es ist
uns ein wichtiges Zeichen dieses Signal
was damit verbunden ist zu senden wir
alle wünschen uns dass dieser
mörderische Krieg den Putin hier gegen
die Ukraine wird bald endet aber danach
sieht es nicht aus und weil das so ist
sehen wir es als unsere Aufgabe an die
Ukraine zu unterstützen dieses neue
waffenpaket enthält 30 Leopard eins
Panzer 20 Marder 18 Rathaus Betzen vier
Flugabwehrsysteme 200 aufklärungsdrohnen
und weiteres Gesamtwert 2,7 Milliarden
Euro
wir sind nicht nur routinierter geworden
sondern es Verteidigungsministerium
arbeitet mit dem Wirtschaftsministerium
was die Ausfuhr der Waffen genehmigen
soll aber es ist vor allen Dingen der
politische Wille da endlich ohne zu
zögern das zu liefern was die Ukraine
braucht von dort aus der Ukraine heute
dafür viel Applaus alles wird gebraucht
für die angekündigte Gegenoffensive nur
das deutsche Timing sei noch steigerbar
so der ukrainische Außenminister
Deutschland hat schon viel gemacht
natürlich muss man über den Zeitplan
reden denn wir brauchen immer alles so
schnell wie möglich
in Deutschland aber sind längst nicht
alle einverstanden mit Waffenlieferungen
im alltempo obwohl die Bevölkerung sich
von der Bundesregierung den Einsatz für
Verhandlungen gewünscht wird quasi im
Vorbeigehen die militärische
Unterstützung verdoppelt ich halte das
für verteilen dass die Bundesregierung
immer in ihrem militärischen Tunnelblick
verbleibt auch in Aachen bereiten Sie
sich vor sich selber auf einen hohen
Gast vor hier wird morgen der Karlspreis
verliehen an selenski und des ukra
himmlische Volk nicht ausgeschlossen
dass der Präsident den Preis persönlich
abholt
deutsche Waffenlieferungen so ganz ohne
Streit und monatelanges hin und her da
müssen wir Nachfragen bei chakota La
bernergy in Berlin warum ging es diesmal
so geräuschlos Schack unter der welche
Bedeutung hat dieses Paket ihr
geräuschlos und schnell muss man auch
sagen denn das Paket ist in nur acht
Tagen geschnürt worden so sagt es heute
Boris Pistorius man hat also neben dem
politischen Willen offensichtlich auch
neue Quellen bzw bessere Quellen für das
Material gefunden dass man da braucht es
muss dieses Mal nicht aus der Bundeswehr
entnommen werden heißt es sondern kommt
direkt von der Industrie und das ganze
ist ein Signal dass Deutschland ist
ernst meint mit seiner Unterstützung so
heute auch noch mal der
Verteidigungsminister man muss
allerdings auch dazu sagen dass selenski
das Material im übertragenen Sinne nicht
morgen mit nach Hause nehmen kann
sondern dass das ganze noch ein bisschen
dauert weil das Material zum Teil
aufbereitet zum Teil neue produziert
werden muss das heißt es geht um Wochen
oder Monate und morgen dann also Deutsch
ukraineische Gespräche im Kanzleramt und
Karl Preisverleihung in Aachen wie
harmonisch wird das werden
also die Vorzeichen stehen gar nicht so
schlecht nachdem die Ukraine ja sehr
lange unzufrieden gewesen ist und immer
wieder gesagt hat Deutschland und die
Bundesregierung seien zu zögerlich bei
der Unterstützung hat sich das Bild
jetzt aktuell gewandelt man hört heute
aus der Ukraine zu dem neuen
angekündigten neuen waffenpaket sehr
positive Töne da heißt es dass da in
historisches Paket und der Berater von
selensky podoljak hat gesagt Deutschland
übernehme jetzt die Führung also da
stimmt momentan die Chemie und dann
gibt's eben morgen auch noch den
Karlspreis die Verleihung in Aachen da
soll Olaf Scholz die Laudatio halten und
das ist ja auch eine starke symbolische
Geste also es könnten ganz gute
Vorzeichen sein für einen Besuch mit
positiven Tönen und du wirst uns davon
berichten vielen Dank für die nach
Berlin
und jetzt eine überraschende eine gute
Nachricht der 50-stündige Bahn Streik
der morgen Abend beginnen sollte ist
abgesagt die Deutsche Bahn hat einen
Eilantrag gegen den Streik beim
Arbeitsgericht in Frankfurt am Main
eingereicht und offenbar ist der
Richterin gelungen was die Tarifparteien
in ihren Verhandlungen bislang nicht
geschafft haben nämlich eine Art
Kompromiss zu schmieden beide Seiten
sind nun wieder bereit zu verhandeln der
Streik ist zumindest vorerst vom Tisch
Inken Klinge war beim Gerichtstermin
dabei
immer wieder schlägt die zuständige
Richterin einen Vergleich vor und deutet
an dass sie Zweifel an der
Rechtmäßigkeit des angekündigten Streiks
habe doch es muss mehrmals umformuliert
werden bis die eisenbahngewerkschaft EVG
dem Vergleich zustimmt der Knackpunkt
der gesetzliche Mindestlohn auf den
manche Mitarbeitende bislang nur durch
eine Zulage kommen schließlich einigt
man sich mit der Bahn auch um einen
konstruktiven verhandlungsfortgang zu
erreichen wie es heißt
der Arbeitgeber hat heute vor Gericht
unmissverständlich erklärt dass er
unsere Forderungen zumindestlohn erfüllt
auf Anraten des Gerichts haben beide
Parteien daraufhin einen Vergleich
geschlossen vor diesem Hintergrund
setzen wir den Streik bei der Deutschen
Bahn vorerst aus sollte der Arbeitgeber
wortbrüchig werden werden wir erneut zu
einem Streik aufrufen die Züge der
Deutschen Bahn werden also erst einmal
weiter rollen zumindest die meisten
teilt die Bahn erleichtert mit sie
können sich darauf einstellen dass am
Montag und Dienstag sehr umfassender
Bahnverkehr stattfinden wird die wurde
nicht ganz alle Züge fahren werden aber
im Wesentlichen wird miteinander mein
Bahnverkehr haben manch ein reisen da
kann kaum glauben dass der 50-stündige
Streik vom Tisch ist ach das ist ja
genial wie bitte ist jetzt kein Witz ne
ich weiß auch nicht wie herzlos muss man
sein dass man eine Muttertag so einen
Wandschrank aufruft also das verstehe
ich nicht ich finde das ganz ganz gut
nein tatsächlich würde ich mich aber
freuen wenn die Leute alle mehr Geld
verdienen
für den Politikwissenschaftler Wolfgang
Schröder ist dieser Kompromiss vor
Gericht eine Situation die nicht zur
Regel werden sollte zwischen
Konfliktparteien in einem Tarifstreit
weil es war offensichtlich dass sich
hier beide Kontrahenten verhakt haben
und deshalb hätten beide die Notbremse
vorher ziehen müssen das betrifft aber
nicht nur die EVG sondern auch das
Management weil wir erleben seit
mittlerweile zehn Jahren in diesem
Konzern eine Kultur des Konfliktes die
EVG betont dass der Warnstreik bei der
Deutschen Bahn zwar abgesagt wurde für
einige andere regionale Bahnunternehmen
gelte der Streik Aufruf aber weiterhin
der amerikanische Präsident Joe Biden
hatte vorsichtshalber Chaos für eine
gewisse Zeit vorausgesagt wenn Politiker
so was ankündigen heißt das dass sie
sich Sorgen machen in diesem Fall sorgen
dass Tausende von Migranten über die
Grenze zwischen Mexiko und den USA
stürmen könnten der Grund für diese
Warnung ist dass eine noch von Donald
Trump verhängte Regelung ausgelaufen ist
dies ermöglichte Migranten ohne
Asylverfahren zurückzuschicken beides
Problem er hatte eine andere eine
humanere Flüchtlingspolitik versprochen
aber gleichzeitig die Republikaner im
Nacken die im heraufziehen den Wahlkampf
Ängste veröffentlichen Grenzen schüren
sie brauchen Strom aus Amerika Laden
gleich am Grenzzaun nahe San Diego ihre
Handys auf denn sie haben nur dann eine
Chance auf den Termin bei den
Kontrollstellen wenn Sie sich über die
App der us-einwanderungsbehörde anmelden
hunderte Haaren hier weiter auskämpfen
mit der Technik raus frustriert wenn die
App mal funktioniert sind nach wenigen
Minuten alle Termine vergeben
wenn du es nicht in ein zwei Minuten
schaffst dann musst du wieder warten bis
zum nächsten Tag zur gleichen Zeit
im texanischen El Paso läuft es
überraschend geordnet der Ansturm der
letzten Tage ist ein Stück weit vererbt
viele vertrauen darauf dass ihr asylan
liegen sorgfältig geprüft wird auch vor
der Notunterkunft in der Stadt ist es
deutlich ruhiger als zuvor aber rund
1800 kam noch am Donnerstag aber danach
haben wir keine großen Zahlen mehr
gesehen hier in der Gegend
offenbar wirkt auch die Abschreckung
denn wenn die Polizei beim illegalen
Grenzübertritt erwischt der wird hart
bestraft fünf Jahre lang dürfen Sie
keinen Asylantrag mehr stellen die
US-Regierung hat Mexiko zum sicheren
Drittland erklärt sie hätten dort Asyl
erbitten oder die App nutzen müssen die
Zahl der Abschiebungen in Länder wie
Guatemala und honduras ist in den
letzten Tagen deutlich gewachsen
die Familie gewahra aus wenn esuela
hatte Glück sie darf während ihres
Asylverfahrens bleiben die
Gerichtstermine erzählt Edison sei bald
in New York sie hätten kein Geld um
dorthin zu gelangen und dennoch die
Hoffnung auf eine bessere Zukunft aber
nicht überall sind die Zuwanderer
willkommen
warum habt ihr uns nicht gefragt empören
sich Bürger in Chicago denn in ihrer
Nachbarschaft soll eine alte Schule zur
Flüchtlingsunterkunft umgebaut werden
viele Städte sind vom Ansturm der
letzten Wochen überwältigt auch deshalb
fordern die Republikaner ein viel
schärferes Vorgehen vielen Demokraten
gehen Joe bidens strenge Regeln zu weit
der Präsident steht im Wahlkampf massiv
unter Druck er lässt die Auffanglager
jetzt noch einmal vergrößern für den
Fall dass doch hunderttausende kommen
noch sieht es auf der mexikanischen
Seite nah San Diego nicht danach aus und
wer schon da ist versucht wenigstens den
neuen Regeln zu folgen
und hier geht es weiter mit den
Nachrichten und mit Hanna Zimmermann im
Nahen Osten stehen die Zeichen offenbar
vorerst auf Deeskalation nach Angaben
des Islamischen Jihad hat sich die
Extremistengruppe mit Israel auf eine
Waffenruhe geeinigt laut Medienberichten
bestätigte auch das Büro des
israelischen Premiers Netanjahu den
Waffenstillstand dennoch wurden am Abend
nach dem bekannt werden Raketenangriffe
gemeldet seit Dienstag hatte die
israelische Luftwaffe Ziele im
Gazastreifen bombardiert und militante
Palästinenser feuerten Raketen auf
Israel mehr als 30 Menschen kamen
seitdem ums Leben
während der corona-pandemie hatte die
Bundesregierung den Zugang zum
Kurzarbeitergeld vereinfacht Ende Juni
soll diese Sonderregel nun Auslaufen das
erklärte Bundesarbeitsminister Heil in
der Rheinischen Post die wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung und die Lage auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt seinen aktuell besser als
erwartet sagte er ab Juli gilt somit
wieder die alte Regel damit
Kurzarbeitergeld beantragt werden kann
muss mindestens ein Drittel der
Beschäftigten eines Unternehmens
betroffen sein momentan sind es zehn
Prozent
morgen wird in Bremen eine neue
Bürgerschaft gewählt heute haben die
Spitzenkandidaten noch einmal um Stimmen
geworden die SPD und Regierungschef
bovenschulte würden gern in ihrer
aktuellen Koalition mit den Grünen und
den linken weiter regieren auf einen
Wechsel hofft dagegen die CDU mit
Spitzenkandidat Imhoff die
Christdemokraten liegen in aktuellen
Umfragen hinter der SPD
zu den Lottozahlen an diesem Samstag die
lauten 1 4 12 26 28 39 Superzahl 1 alle
Angaben wie immer ohne Gewähr
fehlt noch der Blick auf die ziemlich
durchwachsenen Wetteraussichten morgen
kommen nach einem oft sonnigen Start ab
Mittag Schauer und Gewitter auf südlich
der Donau sind die Wolken meist dicht am
Nachmittag setzt hier Dauerregen ein die
Temperatur erreicht 12 bis 23 Grad auch
in den nächsten Tagen bleiben uns der
Regen und die Gewitter erhalten erst am
Mittwoch wird es von Norden her sonniger
und trockener mit 9 bis 18 Grad wird es
am Mittwoch etwas kühler
und das war es von uns hier geht es
jetzt weiter mit dem Sportstudio und
Dunja Hayali und die nächsten
Nachrichten gibt es gegen 0 Uhr 20 heute
Express mit Jessica sahidi und uns gibt
es morgen wieder schönen Abend tschüss
tschüss
[Musik]